[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonjour la
présidente madame la Présidente
l'insécurité que nos concitoyens
rencontrent sur Internet sappe leur
confiance dans la transition numérique
et tous les Français sont concernés par
les désordes en tout genre qui
s'accumule dans l'espace numérique et en
particulier les Français les plus
vulnérables bonjour bienvenue dans ce
nouveau numéro des grands débats
consacré à la régularisation et la
sécurisation de l'espace numérique les
objectifs de ce projet de loi la lutte
contre la désinformation le
cyberharcèlement les contenus incitants
à la haine mais aussi la protection des
mineurs face à la pornographie si le
gouvernement et la majorité défendent un
texte de protection certaines
oppositions dénoncent un risque pour les
libertés nos concitoyens les plus âgés
ou les plus éloignés du numérique qui
sont les proies privilégiés des
cybercriminels nos enfants qui sont
victimes en ligne d'atteinte brutale à
leur innocence nos entreprises que la
loi du plus fort place dans une
situation d'assujétissement vis-àis des
géants du numérique et notre démocratie
qui subit les coups de bouttoir
incessants des professionnel de la
désinformation et des ingénieurs du
chaos face à cela depuis 6 ans la France
sous l'impulsion du Président de la
République a agi au niveau national avec
des lois visant la désinformation la
protection de l'enfance en ligne au
niveau européen avec la construction
d'un socle de régulation de l'espace
numérique européen et au niveau
international avec des initiatives
prises par le Président de la République
comme l'appel de Christ Church ou le
forum de Paris sur la paix qui ont
contribué à éveiller la conscience
mondiale sur ces sujets le projet de loi
qui vous a proposé de d'examiner
poursuit le même objectif et s'est formé
à partir de trois affluents le premier
le premier affluent
c'est ce sont les deux règlements que la
France aorté et qui ont été adoptés au
niveau européen l'année dernière et que
nous devons pour qu'il puisse se
s'appliquer correctement à adapté dans
notre droit français ces deux règlements
il mettent fin à une quinzaine d'années
pendant lesquelles les géants du
numérique se retrancher derrière les
différences de nos législations
nationales au niveau européen pour fuir
toute forme de responsabilité c'est
d'abord le Règlement sur les services
numériques le DSA qui fait rentrer ces
grandes plateformes dans l'aair de la
responsabilité en exigeant d'elle
qu'elle partage leurs données avec les
chercheurs qu'ell fassent auditer leurs
algorithmes qu'elles s'abstiennent de
faire de la publicité ciblée sur les les
mineurs et qu'elles tiennent compte et
corrigent le risque systémique qu'elles
font peser sur la santé de leurs
utilisateurs sur la qualité du débat
public ou encore sur la sécurité
publique le deuxième règlement c'est le
Règlement sur les marchés numériques qui
lui vient mettre fin aux pratiques
commerciales déloyales qui ont permis à
des géants du numérique de s'octroyer
des positions de monopole sur certains
marchés plaçant les entreprises
européennes les collectivités les
administrations et même les particuliers
dans un lien de dépendance et empêchant
les entreprises européennes concurrentes
d'entrer sur ces marchés et c'est ainsi
que ce règlement sur les marchés
numériques édicte 26 pratiques qui
seront désormais interdites dans les
États-membres de l'Union européenne la
préinstallation d'un navigateur d'un
moteur de recherche ou d'un assistant
personnel sur un smartphone
l'autopréférence qui consiste à
faire apparaître de manière plus
favorable ses propres services que ceux
de ses concurrents ou encore
l'utilisation des données collectées sur
l'un euh des services d' proposés par
une entreprise pour faire de la
publicité sur un autre de ces services
autant de pratiques qui seront désormais
interdites et au final euh le le fil
rouge de ce texte qui vous a proposé
d'examiner euh c'est celui de la
protection de nos concitoyens de nos
enfants euh de nos entreprises et
collectivités dans l'espace numérique au
chapitre de la protection de nos
concitoyens d'abord trois mesures
importantes la première c'est le filtre
anti-arnaque qui servira de rempart
contre les camp ne de SMS frauduleux
nous avons tous reçu des faux SMS de la
sécurité sociale des impôts de la
vignette critère nous avons tous hésiter
à cliquer et en réalité ce sont 18
millions de Français qui ont été
victimes l'année dernière de la
cyberciminalité et en particulier les
Français les plus âgés les plus
vulnérables qui se retrouvent entraînés
dans la spirale infernale de
l'usurpation d'identité dont ils mettent
parfois une décennie avant de se sortir
avec cette mesure nous voulons couper le
mal à la racine et je me réjouis des
travaux de la commission spéciale qui
ont permis de clarifier le rôle
notamment des navigateurs je pense au
rapporteur aux amendements rapporteur et
ce d'éc botorel dans le le le dispositif
et qui va permettre de le sécuriser de
le rendre un peu plus efficace on a
aussi précisé la définition du
hamsonnage dans le cadre de ces débats
deuxième mesure la peine de bannissement
peine complémentaire que le juge pourra
prononcer pour des faits de violence et
de harcèlement euh en ligne le
harcèlement se propage sur les réseaux
sociaux les respons les responsables en
sont une minorité d'internautes qui
parfois se comportent comme des chefs de
meutes qui désignent à leur communauté
euh des victimes et qui déclenchent sur
eux des haines ou sur ell des aides des
raides de haine et de violence et je dis
sur elle puisque les femmes sont 26 fois
plus souvent victimes de
cyberharcèlement que les hommes euh sur
internet avec cette peine de
bannissement nous préviendrons euh la la
récidive en tapant ses chefs de meut là
où ça fait mal puisqu'en confisquant
leur notoriété nous les privons nous les
priverons de leur caisse de résonance
troisème mesure de protection
l'encadrement des jeux fondés sur les
chaînes de bloc fondé sur le web 3 ces
jeux existent depuis un certain nombre
d'années ils ne sont aujourd'hui l'objet
d'aucun cadre de protection protection
des mineurs protection contre les
addictions lutte contre le blanchiment
et le financement du terrorisme le cadre
qui est proposé et là aussi je veux
saluer le le travail remarquable des
rapporteurs sur sur ce sujet permettra
de de faciliter le développement en
France
d'innovation tout en protégeant celles
et ceux qui ont besoin de l'être au
chapitre de la protection de nos enfants
ensuite une mesure forte qui consiste à
confier à l'arcom le pouvoir d'ordonner
le blocage et le déréférencement des
sites pornographiques qui ne vérifieront
pas l'âge de leurs utilisateurs et il
est urgent de prendre cette mesure parce
que comme vous le savez ce sont plus de
2 millions d'enfants qui dans notre pays
sont exposés chaque mois au contenu
pornographique et a des âge extrêmement
précocece puisque'à 12 ans dans notre
pays la moitié des petits garçons sont
exposés à ces contenus avec des
conséquences délétaires sur leur santé
et sur leur développement affectif
pourquoi parce que les sites
pornographiques ne vérifient pas l'âge
de leurs utilisateurs alors qu'ils y
sont tenus par la loi une procédure est
en cours qui ira jusqu'à son terme et
dont je souhaite que euh le le verdict
euh soit exemplaire mais pour l'avenir
il nous faut pouvoir agir plus vite et
avec cette mesure euh nous euh nous le
pourrons certaines inquiétudes se sont
exprimées pendant la commission euh sur
la confusion possible entre les
obligations de moyens et les obligations
de résultats euh qui s'imposeront au
sites pornographiques euh les
rapporteurs ont proposé une rédaction
qui me semble aller dans le bon sens en
rappelant bien euh que l'obligation
absolue c'est celle de se conformer au
code pénal qui interdit à quiconque
d'exposer des mineurs dans notre pays à
des contenus pornographiques 2è mesure
au chapitre de la protection de nos
enfants la la peine d'un an de prison et
250000 € d'amende pour les hébergeurs
qui ne retireront pas en moins de 24
heures les contenus pédopornographiques
qui leur sont signalés par les forces de
l'ordre l'année dernière ce sont
74000 contenus pédopornographiques qui
ont été signalés par Faros à des
hébergeurs aujourd'hui cette obligation
existe celle du retrait en moins de 24
heures mais elle n'est pas sanctionnée
par une amende ou par une peine de
prison à l'inverse de la peine déjà
prévue pour le non retrait de contenu
terroriste nous alignons avec cet
article les sanctions pour les le
nonretrait des contenus
pédopornographiques avec celui avec
celle prévue pour le non retrait des
contenus euh terroriste j'eneviens
maintenant au chapitre de la protection
de nos entreprises et de nos
collectivités avec d'abord l'encadrement
des avoirs commerciaux
l'interopérabilité et l'interdiction des
frais de transfert dans le marché de
l'informatique en nuage c'est un marché
qui est extrêmement concentré entre les
mains de trois acteurs euh qui se sont
livrés à des pratiques déloyales pour
consolider au fil des années un
oligopole sur ce marché plaçant les
entreprises utilisatrices les
collectivités utilisatrices les
administrations utilisatrices dans une
situation d'assujettissement et de
dépendance
nous devons mettre fin à la loi du plus
fort c'est une question de souveraineté
à laquelle avec Bruno Le Maire nous
veillons extrêmement attentivement avec
ces mesures qui elles aussi ont fait
l'objet d'enrichissement et d'apport
nouveaux par le travail des rapporteurs
et de la commission spéciale nous
rendrons de l'air et de la liberté aux
entreprises de France et au au passage
nous réouvrirons ce marché de l'info de
l'informatique en nuage qui est
aujourd'hui très significativement
verrouillé et puis une mesure de
protection pour nos collectivités avec
la création d'une plateforme unique pour
le respect de la réglementation en
matière de meublé de tourisme il s'agit
là de péréniser c'est une c'est un
souhait de la ministre Olivia Grégoire
une expérimentation qui a commencé il y
a quelques années associant cinq
collectivités avec cinq plateformes et
qui permettra de manière beaucoup plus
simple aux collectivités de faire
respecter en particulier la règle des
120 nuités j'en viens au 4e chapitre de
la protection de notre démocratie avec
le pouvoir donné à l'arcom de mettre en
demeure et d'ordonner le blocage le cas
échéant des sites Internet qui
diffuseront des médias frappés par des
sanctions internationales à l'image de
celle que l'Union européenne a prise à
l'encontre de RT France et de spoutnck
la désinformation est un véritable
poison pour nos démocratie avec cette
mesure qui elle aussi a été complétée
utilement par des amendements de de
Quentin bataillon lors de l'examen de la
en commission et bien nous allons
compléter notre arsenal de mesures pour
lutter plus efficacement contre les
ennemis de la démocratie il nous faudra
veiller collectivement à ne jamais
enfreindre les bornes que nous fixent
les engagements européens de la France
et notre Constitution les engagements le
respect des engagements européens de la
France c'est ce qui permet à la France
d'obtenir de grandes victoires comme ça
a été le cas à de nombreuses reprises C
dernières années et singulièrement en
2022 avec l'adoption de DSA et de DMA on
ne peut pas tricoter de grandes victoire
à Bruxelles si on les détricote le
lendemain en rentrant à Paris c'est
parfois un peu frustrant mais c'est une
exence que l'on doit avoir quand on
enemporte pour l'Europe une une vision
ambitieuse et quant à notre Constitution
elle veille à ce que les mesures que
nous prenons les mesures indispensables
que nous prenons pour sécuriser l'espace
numérique ne viennent pas pas enfreintre
de manière disproportionnée les libertés
fondamentales et je pense évidemment à
la liberté d'information et la liberté
d'expression mesdames et messieurs les
députés la France ne tiendra pas son
rang de grande nation numérique si les
français et notamment les plus
vulnérables ne se sentent pas en
sécurité sur Internet ce constat je sais
que nous le partageons très largement et
quant aux réponses à lui apporter je
sais pouvoir compter sur la sagesse de
l'Assemblée alors merci beaucoup la
parole est à Monsieur Paul midi
rapporteur général de la mission
spéciale nous passons déjà plus de temps
dans l'espace numérique que dans
l'espace public en moyenne ce sont 4
heur par jour que les Français passent
dans l'espace numérique et même pour nos
jeunes de 15 à 24 ans 4 heures par jour
et ça continue d'augmenter chaque année
alors cet espace numérique ce sont bien
sûr les réseaux sociaux ce sont les
plateformes de contenu vidéo ce sont nos
magasins en ligne sont nos jeux vidéos
ou encore ce sont nos musées en version
virtuelle cet espace numérique c'est un
un espace d'opportunités immense c'est
un espace de lien entre les uns et les
autres de partage avec les amis la
famille avec l'ensemble des concitoyens
de la communauté nationale européenne et
mondiale c'est un espace de création
fantastique l'espace numérique c'est un
espace de libertés individuelle qui sont
très importantes notamment la liberté de
s'exprimer bien sûr mais aussi la
liberté de s'informer mais cet espace
numérique c'est un petit peu aujourd'hui
le Far West plus de 50 % de nos jeunes
disent s'être fait harceler en ligne
avec des conséquences bien souvent trop
dramatiques je pense par exemple au cas
très récent de Manon Lanza qui après son
accident dans GP explorer s'est fait
littéralement lyché harcelé de remarques
CCIS par des milliers d'internautes mais
je pense aussi au suicide de la jeune
Linsey cyber harcelé à l'école et à
l'appel de sa mère à la puissance
publique pour combattre je la cite
l'impunité sur les réseaux sociaux qui
ne peuvent Contin uer à gagner de
l'argent sur les propos aineux et
injurieux je ne veux pas moi vivre dans
un monde où parce que tout le monde se
sent anonyme il y a un sentiment
d'impunité et ça donne un suicide suite
à du harcèlement toutes les de semaines
et un niveau de violence inégalé dans le
monde
physique 2è point 50 % des arnaques ont
maintenant lieu en ligne ce sont 9
millions de Français nos compatriotes
qui perdre de l'argent dans ces arnaques
nous avons tous reçu ce type de SMS par
exemple pour les fausses amondes et ce
sont aussi 80 % de nos enfants parfois
les plus jeunes qui ont été exposés à la
pornographie à cause d'Internet avec des
troubles maintenant prouvé sur leur
comportement à l'adolescence et à l'âge
adulte et puis d'une façon générale pour
ceux comme 80 % des Français qui sont
utilisateurs quotidiens des réseaux
sociaux c'est misogynie sexisme racisme
antisémitisme islamophobie et lgbtphobie
à tous les étages et nous devons donc
trouver les moyens d'y mettre fin le
chcientier donc immense pour rendre
notre espace numérique aussi civilisé et
sûr que notre espace physique nous en
venons à la discussion générale la
parole est à Monsieur Aurélien tacher
pour le groupe écologiste nupes vous
souhaitez chers collègues de la majorité
que le numérique ressemble au réel mais
moi je veux que ce qui est aujourd'hui
un des derniers espaces de liberté soit
soumis ne soit pas soumis à des
contrôles injustifiés au nom de la
sécurité le projet de loi qui arrive
aujourd'hui dans notre assemblée risque
pourtant si on y prend pas garde de
renforcer cette logique de société de
surveillance cette société de du
contrôle permanent et de faire reculer
ces précieuses libertés vous voulez par
exemple mettre fin à l'exposition des
mineurs à la pornographie on est
évidemment d'accord sur cet objectif
loin des jugements moraux ou d'un
quelconque puritanisme il s'agit
d'éviter qu'une majorité d'enfants ne
découvr la sexualité à travers des
pratiques souvent bien éloignées de la
réalité parfois extrême et même illégal
qu'il risque de reproduire ensuite mais
c'est d'abord par l'éducation et la
prévention ou en renforçant les
possibilités de contrôle donné aux
parents que nous devons atteindre cette
ambition ainsi qu'en faisant peser la
responsabilité de la régulation sur
l'industrie pornographique elle-même et
non sur l'administration car le système
que vous nous proposez repose sur une
logique de surveillance et d'exclusion
en donnant à l'arcom le pouvoir de
contrôler l'identité des utilisateurs et
de fermer directement les sites qui
contreviennent à leurs obligations vous
vous allez finalement mettre deux
risques en en exerg un d'abord de
censure du web car ça devrait être à la
justice indépendante de procéder à ces
fermetures l'extension de ce principe
pourrait en effet conduire demain en
étant dans l'émission de l'arcom estce
qu'elle puisse fermer tout site qui ne
convient pas au gouvernement et je crois
que c'est inutile de de démontrer
pourquoi la démocratie et les libertés
se trouveraient menacé la tentation qui
a eu par exemple à un moment de mettre
dans ce texte et je vous salue monsieur
le ministre de ne pas l'avoir fait de
couper les réseaux sociaux et
messageries dans certaines situation
démontre que cette tentation est bien
présente vous ouvrez aussi une brèche
dangereuse sur la protection de
l'anonymat pour l'instant elle serait
limitée au site pornographique mais on
voit bien à travers vos propositions mon
cher collègue Paul midi que ça pour
pourrait être qu'une première étape or
le respect de l'anonym sur internet ça
doit rester une ligne rouge c'est ce qui
permet à des journalistes
d'investigation à des lanceurs d'alerte
de travailler sinement et de nous
fournir certaines informations dont nous
avons besoin en tant que citoyen comment
serons-nous informés demain sur des
sujets internationaux de corruption
d'abus des autorités sans garantir les
signalements anonymes c'est le même
danger que pourrait entraîner la
généralisation de de l'identité
numérique ou le blocage direct des sites
web par l'État à travers le filtre
anti-arnaque que vous aviez initialement
imaginé il est vrai nous l'avons déjà
dit que la lutte contre les arnaques
notamment à travers les influenceurs
doit devenir une priorité mais cela ne
peut se faire au détriment des libertés
numériques et en faisant peser sur les
navigateurs des obligations démesurées
n'oublions pas que la gouvernance
d'Internet repose sur un consortium
mondial et que si demain la France les
oblige à fermer eux-mêmes certains sites
les régimes autoritaires qui jusqu'ici
n'avait jamais rien demandé ne se
priveront pas eux aussi de de de
demander cela au navigateurs et ce ne
seront pas seulement les sites d'arnaque
qui seront visés nous le savons vous et
moi la protection de nos données la
souveraineté numérique sont essentiels
mais pas au prix de nos libertés et pour
vraiment sécuriser l'espace numérique
c'est surtout à ces géants du numérique
que sont les gfames que vous auriez dû
vous attaquer notamment au quasi
monopole dont il dispose pour stocker
nos données mais ça ne vous dérange pas
que ces gigantesques entreprises qui
échappent déjà pour beaucoup à
l'imposition et qui créent une
concurrence déloyale sur le monde de la
technologie française puisse avoir
autant accès à autant d'information sur
la population qu'elle stock dans des
serveurs à l'étranger la parole est à
Madame Soumia bourois pour le groupe
Gauche démocrate et républicaine nupes
le premier enjeu de ce texte est
l'articulation du principe et d'égal
valeur la protection des enfants et des
adolescents sur Internet est un
impératif mais doit se concilier avec le
droit de la vie privée en matière de
pornographie nous nous inscrivons
pleinement dans la volonté du
gouvernement de restreindre réellement
l'accès aux mineurs et de faire
appliquer
enfin l'interdiction d'accès nous savons
toutes et tous les dégâts que cela fait
sur les plus jeunes exposés aux
pratiques les plus violentes sex
raciste quelle représentation des femmes
du corps de l'autre cela entraîne
comment ne pas lutter contre une
industrie où le viol est constamment
présent le rapport de la délégation des
droits des femmes porno l'enfer du décor
du Sénat nous a servi de base de travail
pour ce texte et je m'en félicite nous
soutiendrons l'ensemble des mesures qui
en sont issues
cependant cette vérification de l'âge
doit comporter des garanties en matière
de droit à la vie privée les éditeurs ne
doivent pas posséder les données des
utilisateurs nous plaidons pour une
technologie en double anonymat par un
tiers de confiance nous ne pouvons
vérifier l'âge à n'importe quel prix je
souhaite également alerter sur l'article
3 qui contourne des mots même du
ministre le juge judiciaire l'alignement
sur le régime antiterroriste avec des
retraits de contenu dans des délais
extrêmement court et dans les mains des
autorités administratives ne nous
apparaît pas la réponse adaptée à force
de contourner la justice nous
affaiblissons petit à petit l'État de
droit cette même difficulté apparaît à
l'article 6 là encore si nous ne pouvons
que partager l'objectif contre les
arnaques en ligne nous refitons nous
réfutons la possibilité pour une
autorité administrative d'imposer le
blocage de l'accès à un service de
communication au public en ligne en
raison des risques importants pour
l'exercice des libertés individuelles le
blocage de site ne devrait être autorisé
que par un juge judiciaire afin de
vérifier que la demande n'est ni
horonnée ni abusive au regard des
libertés fondamental de même nous nous
opposons à l'expérimentation concernant
les jeunes hones nous ouvrons une brèche
importante dans l'interdiction sauf
dérogation des jeux d'argent et de
hasard il est pourtant estimé à 1,4 4
millions de joueurs à risque 400000 à un
niveau pathologique dans notre pays il y
a un enjeu véritablement de santé
publique qui est totalement absent de ce
texte la parole est à Monsieur
Christophe nagelen pour le groupe
liberté indépendant outre mer et
territoire internet a été créé avec un
idéal celui d'un monde où la libre
circulation de l'information
favoriserait la liberté d'expression la
diffusion des connaissances la création
en fin de compte l'innovation
aujourd'hui cette utopie menace de virer
à la zisanie l'espace numérique est
devenu celui de la concentration des
entreprises de la polarisation politique
et des comportements répréhensibles pour
qu'Internet reste un lieu de liberté où
chacun puisse se sentir en sécurité et
où la concurrence recommence à s'exercer
il est nécessaire de
réguler cette régulation nous le savons
doit prioritairement se faire à
l'échelle européenne puisque c'est là où
elle sera le plus efficace c'est
d'ailleurs l'objet des quatre règlements
adoptés entre 2022 et 2023 DSA DMA DGA
et data Act notre groupe se montre bien
entendu favorable à la trans aux mesures
de transposition de ces directive
nécessaire pour adapter notre droit à ce
nouveau cadre de
régulation nous devons aussi à l'échelle
nationale cette fois-ci nous montrer
plus protecteur vis-à-vis des
internautes les plus fragiles c'est
notamment l'objet des titres 1 et 2
concernant les mineurs qui sont
massivement exposés au contenu
pornographique sur le net confier à
l'arcom le soin de mettre en place un un
référentiel va dans le bon sens de même
que la solution qui nous a été présentée
par le gouvernement de double anonymat
il reste qu'il faudra élargir son usage
à d'autres application que la
pornographie pour qu'il y ait un réel
anonymat des internautes la parole est à
Monsieur auréli Lopez ligori pour le
groupe rassemblement
national les élus de la minorité
présidentielle ne cessent de distribuer
des leçons de morale sur la liberté et
la démocratie mais vous piétinez ces
valeurs aujourd'hui avec le projet de
loi sécurisé et réuliel numérique en
soutenant l'obligation de lier
l'identité numérique à l'identité
physique c'est-à-dire en supprimant
l'anonyat en ligne vous vous attaquez à
la philosophie même de ce qu'est
internet internet est et doit rester un
espace de liberté en obligeant les
Français à fournir leurs documents
d'identité pour accéder aux réseaux
sociaux vous ferez d'Internet une
parodie de safe space walk autocensuré
sans débat sans dialogue sans vie cette
fin de l'anonymat que vous préparez est
liberticide mais surtout
inefficace tout simplement parce que la
loi existe et qu'elle est d'ors et déjà
bien faite quand une infraction est
constatée il y a une réquisition du
procureur
ou une plainte et derrière une enquête
de police puis une condamnation s'il
doit en avoir une le problème
aujourd'hui c'est qu'il n'y a pas assez
d'effectifs et de moyens pour le recueil
des plaintes et des et les enquêtes en
vérité au lieu de donner plus de moyens
à la police et à la justice vous
préférez vous attaquer aux libertés des
Français pire les amendements de
monsieur le rapporteur Paul midi ne sont
en fait que l'arbre qui cache la forêt
car même si ces amendements sont rejetés
l'article 5 de ce texte mais lui aussi
en danger l'anonymat en
ligne en exigeant des réseaux sociaux
qu'ils empêchent la création d'un compte
par un individu condamné en d'autres
termes vous demandez aux réseaux sociaux
d'assumer le flicage des Français à
votre place c'est inacceptable vous avez
perdu
l'esprit enfin les seuls pays qui ont
réussi à bannir l'anonymat sont des
régimes autoritaires comme la Chine
est-ce donc là réellement un modèle dont
vous souhaitez vous
inspirer dernière ligne rouge la
souveraineté numérique et la grande
absente de ce projet de loi comment vous
pouvez-vous prétendre réguler l'espace
numérique si vous entretenez une
dépendance aux multinationales
étrangères ce texte était pourtant le
véhicule parfait pour aborder cet enjeu
de souveraineté numérique et les
sénateurs l'avaient bien compris en
uisant l'article 10 B a qui entendait
réserver la commande publique en matière
de Cloud à des entreprises européennes
et uniquement
[Musique]
européenne pour le traitement et
l'hébergement des données sensibles le
but de cette article était clair
expulser les gfames de la commande
publique et en passant éjecter Microsoft
du Data hub où sont stocker les données
de santé des
Français cela avait deux avantages
évidents d'une part part protéger nos
données sensibles pour des raisons de
sécurité nationale et d'indépendance
stratégique d'autre part de développer
notre propre écosystème numérique et de
favoriser des entreprises françaises
européennes comme scalway numspot ou OVH
qui sont d'ors et déjà prêtes à répondre
aux appels d'offre de
l'État c'est cela l'état stratège que
Marine Le Pen ne cesse d'appeler de ses
vœux c'est un état qui utilise la
commande publique comme un levier non
seul pour exclure tout risque d'ingérant
sur notre sol mais aussi pour permettre
le développement de notre propre
industrie du numérique dans un marché
étouffé par les
gfames la minorité présidentielle a
trahi notre souveraineté et notre
écosystème numérique en supprimant en
commission cet article vous vous moquez
donc
éperdument de notre souveraineté
numérique et vous avez également une
peur bleue de vous attaquer aux intérêts
américains en Europe
alors heureusement il y a tout de même
de bonnes mesures proposées par ce
projet de loi
l'interopérabilité et l'encadrement des
crédits cloud qui permettront aux
clients de ne plus être captif d'un seul
prestataire une meilleure prévention
contre les fraudes en ligne avec le
filtre anti-arnaque et surtout une
meilleure pénalisation des plateformes
qui mettent à disposition des mineurs du
contenu
pornographique mais ça suffit pas à
faire de ce texte une bonne loi la
parole est à Madame ségolen Amot pour le
grouple la France insoumise nupè la
Chine a réinventé le contrôle social à
l'aair du numérique et Macron souhaite
le sien à la
française ce puissant système chinois
technosécuritaire vise à noter pister et
juger les habitants du pays et faire en
sorte que chacun se tienne au carreau
sous peine de ne pas pouvoir emprunter
par exemple les transports en
commun un rêve pour Monsieur Macron et
il ne s'en cache plus depuis l'arrivée
du président Macron nos liberté publique
s'effondre peu à peu les Françaises et
les Français se sont englués dans un
filet sécuritaire dénoncé par les
associations jusqu'aux plus hautes
organisations internationales comme
l'ONU ce qui nous vaut le glorioux titre
de démocratie
défaillante bienvenue en
macronistan CE contrôle de la de la vie
physique est réel et souhaite trouver
son modèle pour nos vies numériques
l'influence chinoise semble avoir porté
ses fruits jusqu'à l'Élysée dans les
politiques liberticides et autoritaires
porté par la macronie vous l'aurez
compris ce texte ne nous convient
absolument pas si nous pouvons nous
accorder sur le constat de l'existence
de violence et d'abus sur Internet
reflet virtuel de ce qui se passe dans
nos vies physiques nous ne pouvons que
nous opposer à la réponse que vous y
apportez ce texte est mensongé et laisse
croire que le recours à des solutions
techniques permettrait de protéger les
mineurs et les les utilisateurs
d'Internet de façon générale la solution
technique que vous vendez à Touva est un
leur abandonné par l'Australie par le
Royaume-Uni et les États-Unis
elle crée un sentiment contre-productif
de protection mais toujours
contournable nous ne cessons de le
répéter il n'existe actuellement aucune
solution technique qui permettent la
vérification de l'âge qui soit
compatible avec le droit au respect de
la vie privée et le droit de l'anonymat
sur Internet même l'arcom l'a récemment
avoué en audition et le référentiel ne
sera pas applicable à court terme ce
texte est hypocrite après la loi avia en
grande partie censurée par le Conseil
constitutionnel ce projet de loi
persiste dans l'absence d'intervention
du juge et propose donc la seule
qualification
de l'infraction par
l'administration cela va dans le sens de
l'accroissement des pouvoirs
administratifs au détriment du pouvoir
judiciaire laissant à l'exécutif des
pouvoirs toujours plus grands et mettant
à mal la séparation des
pouvoirs montesquieux l'un des paires de
la séparation des pouvoirs écrivait que
l'oppression commence toujours par le
sommeil vous ne faites là qu'endormir
les Françaises et les Français et nous
serons toujours présents pour l'en
empêcher dans la rue comme dans cet
hémicycle
la parole est à Monsieur Victor Abert
d'assau pour le groupe les républicains
c'est à la République de reprendre la
main en protégeant nos con citoyens et
en anticipant le comportement les plus à
risque je pense comme vous chers
collègues à nos jeunes parfois perdus et
esselés derrière leur écran à nos aînés
aux populations les plus fragiles
confrontés au vendeurs d'amour au SMS au
mail frauduleux visant à usurper une
identité un numéro de cartes bleu les
coordonnées de cartes bancaires voire de
la sécurité sociale le filtre
anti-arnaque en ce sens apparaît comme
un filtre de protection indispensable
sur l'article 15 et la et la régulation
des jeux numériques à objet monétisable
le groupe les républicains insiste sur
le soutien aux nouvelles technologies et
à l'innovation mais tout en anticipant
les risques associé en proposant donc de
restreindre la portée de cet article de
l'expérimentation au jeux de fantaisie
sportive et épique il ne faut pas que
cette nouvelle réglementation serve
d'appel d'airair à des acteurs qui
chercheraient par tout moyen à
contourner les règles existences et un
premier bilan sera évidemment nécessaire
la parole est à Monsieur Hervé Solignac
pour le groupe socialiste et apparenté
peut-on raisonnablement prétendre
réguler l'espace numérique la question
me semble-t-il se pose tant il est vrai
que cet espace semble se développer en
échappant à toutes les règles toutes les
lois et même parfois les notions les
plus élémentaires de la morale la
technologie avance ses pions le
politique lui court après sans parvenir
à combler son retard depuis 6 ans les
textes régulateurs se sont multipliés au
point de constituer un millefeuille un
peu indigeste disons-le et surtout
impuissant la preuve de cette
impuissance ce sont les 150000 requêtes
annuelles adressées à Faros qui donnent
lieu à une cinquantaine de poursuite
judiciaaires seulement autant dire que
c'est l'impunité qui triomp alors le
chemin est étroit entre ceux qui
considèrent que toute régulation est
attentatoire aux libertés et ceux qui
considèrent qu'on peut bien sacrifier
quelques liberté fondamentales pour
combattre les délincants de la toile
alors d'abord vous nous soumettez un
dispositif pour lutter contre l'accès
des mineurs au sites pornographique
monsieur le ministre vous nous aurez
toujours à vos côtés dans ce combat
d'autant que jusqu'à présent les
plateformes se moquent ouvertement du
législateur et considère qu'elles ont
fait leur travail en faisant cocher la
case je suis majeur à ce stade je ne
peux pas affirmer avec certitude que vos
résultats seront bien meilleurs que ceux
de vos prédécesseurs désormais les
plateformes devront se conformer à un
référentiel que vous nous avez présenté
comme une sorte de boîte à outils or
pour le moment la boîte à outils
ressemble plutôt à une boîte noire dès
lors que le référentiel n'a pas été
élaboré vous nous demandez en effet
d'approuver un objet juridique qui
n'existe pas monsieur le ministre vous
le savez les plateformes n'ont aucune
intention de se conformer à un nouveau
cadre légal elles chercheront par tout
moyen à contourner ce nouveau cadre
elles utiliseront toutes les faiblesses
du référentiel tous les recours
juridiques il convient de les bloquer et
de les soumettre à des sanctions
financières très lourdes quand elles
s'exonéreront de leurs obligations en
tout état de cause tant que 2 millions
et demi de mineurs visiteront chaque
mois un site pornographique on
légifèrera à vide la discussion générale
est
close parmi les mesures clés du texte
l'identité numérique en ligne gratuite
et facultative elle permettrait de
sécuriser les démarches administratives
la séance est
ouverte l'article 4ac actuellement il
dit deux choses il dit on se fixe un
objectif de 80 % de Français qui ont une
identité numérique à 2027 et un objectif
de près de 100 % à 2030 ce prês de 100 %
on en a parlé je pense qu' il est
largement améliorable il a apporté un
peu de confusion il était inspiré de la
réalité des chiffres sur la la CNI
actuelle puisque 97 % des Français ont
une CNI mais évidemment la CNI elle
n'est pas
obligatoire et donc dans cet amendement
on propose d'améliorer l'écriture de
l'article actuel en gardant l'objectif
de 80 % à
2027 mais en fixant trois nouveaux
principes en disant que à 2027 cette
ident é numérique elle doit être 100 %
accessible à 100 % des Français euh en
consacrant le fait qu'elle n'est pas
obligatoire qu'elle est accessible à 100
% des Français pour tous les territoires
quel que soit le niveau d'ilectronisme
par exemple donc c'est très important
qu'on accompagne bien tous les Français
sur ce sujet et elle fixe un nouveau
principe que cette identité numérique
elle doit être est accessible
gratuitement bien sûr on reprend
exactement la même chose que dans la vie
physique sur la CN la CNI elle est
accessible à tous elle n'est pas
obligatoire même si 97 % les Français en
nont et elle est gratuite c'est inscrit
dans le droit c'est très important donc
on repart sur ces principes en
améliorant la rédaction pour rajouter
voilà 100 % accessible gratuitement et
pas de caractère obligatoire évidemment
pour cette identité numérique qui était
notre intention de départ mais depuis on
a retravaillé cette
cette écriture qui je pense est bien
meilleure on a un peti une petite
interrogation sur le donc déjà on salue
caractère facultatif caractère l'idée de
la gratuité l'idée d'aller vers 100 %
des Français donc que ça soit simple et
que chacun puisse en disposer c'est très
bien mais le la deuxième partie et que
80 % en dispose effectivement ça ça
laisserait penser que qu' aurait une
incitation à le faire donc peut-être une
sorte de allez caractère non pas
obligatoire mais une caractère incitatif
qui permettrait de bon voilà vous avez
compris j'ai peur que ça laisse penser
que ça serait un peu obligatoire donc on
vous demande de de de retirer la
dernière partie de la phrase et je
laisserai mon collègue l tombe de de de
vous présenter la deuxième partie de
notre fusée parce que nous si nous
aimons bien les fusé à deux
étages merci pour la transition monsieur
le député sous amend 113 Monsieur L
tombe et effectivement on fonctionne à à
deux à de mains sur ce sur cette am
enfin ces amendement l'idée c'est de
dire puisqu'il y a un objectif à 100 % à
non non obligatoire facultatif mais il a
un objectif à 100 % c'est d'expliquer à
nos concitoyens pourquoi et de dire que
cette identité numérique doit les aider
doit faciliter leur relation avec les
services publics et uniquement avec les
services publics c'est d'ailleurs la
position du gouvernement donc avec ces
deux sous-amendements nous avons et
votre amendement nous avons aujourd'hui
quelque chose qui n permettrait de
pouvoir le voter pour ma part et je l'ai
déjà dit que le premier usage de cette
identité numérique doit être de
faciliter l'accès au droit et faciliter
l'accès au services
public partant de cela
je donnerai un avis favorable à à
l'amendement s'agissant du
sous-amendement de Monsieur latombe
serait proposition de retrait parce que
euh le le la restriction du champ à la
relation entre les usag du les usagers
et le service public me paraît peut-être
un peu excessive j'ai parlé de l'accès
au droit par exemple euh en revanche
s'agissant de l'amendement Balanant
étant donné qu'il préserve l'objectif de
rendre accessible à 100 % des Français
une une identité numérique ce qui est
loin d'être le cas puisqueaujourd'hui
pour avoir une identité numérique
réalienne il faut d'abord avoir
bénéficier de la nouvelle carte
nationale d'identité et le simple fait
de maintenir dans l'amendement cet
objectif de 100 % à l'horizon 2027 euh
entraînera de la part de l'État une
réponse je dirais vigoureuse pour faire
en sorte que toutes celles et ceux qui
souhaitent pouvoir bénéficier de la
carte nationale d'identité et de
l'identité numérique puisse le faire à
la base on est plutôt opposé même
franchement opposé à la première
écriture de l'article où il y avait une
obligation tion de de résultat en fait
pour près de 100 % des Français avoir
une une une identité numérique vous
allez vous allez un petit peu dans notre
sens monsieur le rapporteur en le
mettant à 80 % enfin 100 % puisse y
avoir accès puis 80 % dispose
effectivement mais il y a quand même une
obligation une certaine obligation dans
les 80 % d'entre eux en disposent
effectivement nous on avait un
amendement du groupe d'études donc c'est
l'amendement
555 où on voulait le consentement en
fait une notion de consentement à
l'accès à l'identité numérique mais vu
que potentiellement le le le 1056 va
passer avec des sous-amendements on va
soutenir les deux sous-amendements le
sous-amendement de Monsieur balanan
parce que justement il supprime c'est C
ce caractère un peu obligatoire et
derrière l'amendement de Monsieur laton
parce que bien entendu nous nous voulons
que l'identité numérique reste
uniquement un accès au service public ça
doit le rester et donc c'est nécessaire
que ce soit inscrit dans la loi merci
dis que c'était que les Français bon et
alors les étrangers résidants en France
ils font quoi est-ce qu'ils ont comment
on certifie leur identité ah bah oui
mais donc du coup ça veut dire que ça ne
fait que quand on a non mais c'est c'est
un vrai sujet c'est qu'on va certifier
l'identité de ceux qui en France ont la
nationalité mais celles et ceux dont on
pourrait opérer un certain nombre de
contrôle et des mineurs résident sur le
sur le sol français par exemple mais qui
n'auraiit pas la nationalité eux se
verraient exclus de l'accès cette
certification enfin je sais pas c'est
juste une petite idée que que je vous
pose en passant monsieur le rapporteur
mais sur laquelle on pourrait avoir des
débats bref pourquoi le deuxème pourquoi
le sous-amendement 112 est intéressant
c'est que il évite d'avoir 80 % d'accès
effectif parce que 80 % ça veut dire
qu'on a toute la population en excluant
celles et ceux qui sont trop âgés ou
celles et ceux qui sont trop jeunes bah
oui vous AZ pas demandé à des moins de
10 ans d'avoir une
identité non 97 % monsieur le rapporteur
aujourd'hui on atteint on sature
aujourd'hui sur les réseaux sociaux on
va arriver à 83 % des Français 84 % des
Français qui ont un compte réseaux
sociaux donc si vous dites 80 % des
Français ça veut dire que c'est
quasiment 100 % donc moi je pense qu'il
faut virer ça parce que sinon dire 80 %
c'est faire que en gros tout le monde
qui est en capacité d'avoir un
smartphone dans la vie à cette
obligation donc faut éventuellement un
objectif vague pour l'État comme ça on
se dit 100 % c'est bien il faut que tout
le monde ait son identité numérique mais
derrière il faut évidemment pas garder
l'effectivité de cet
objectif vous dites il y a 80 % des
Français qui sont sur les réseaux
sociaux donc si on fixe l'objectif de ça
80 % à 2027 attention c'est 80 % des
Français qui sont sur les réseau sociaux
aujourd'hui je pense qu'on peut imaginer
qu'à 2027 il y en aura beaucoup plus
mais de toute façon là on parle d'une
façon générale pas le on fait pas le
lien avec les réseaux sociaux voilà donc
je pense que ce qui est bon de comparer
c'est que tous âges confondu c'est 97 %
des Français qui ont une CNI plastique
euh et voilà donc c'est c'est c'est à ce
point de comparaison qu'il est je pense
bon de se comparer voilà merci
beaucoup merci monsieur le rapporteur
général je mets donc au voix le
sous-amendement 1112 avis défavorable
commission sagesse gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre il est
adopté je mets au voix l'amendement
ainsi sousamendé 1056 double avis
favorable commission et gouvernement qui
est pour pour qui est contre il est
adopté et il fait tomber l'amendement
555 je ne peux que féliciter cette
assemblée d'avoir d'avoir amendé cette
cet amendement parce que parce qu'il
était assez effrayant en l'état mais
globalement c'est le enfin on reste nous
sur cette dynamique et et cette ligne
qui est de dire demander à 80 ou plus
pour de la de de la population d'avoir
absolument son identité numérique sur
sur les plateformes de l'État c'est
quelque chose qui est à mes yeux
terriblement effrayant d'autant plus
quand on sait que déjà cet été ce sont
les fichiers de Pôle Emploi qui ont été
piratés avec les données personnelles de
de l'ensemble des bénéficiaires de de
Pôle Emploi ce sont les les fichiers et
donc les données de de santé euh
hautement plus grave euh qui ont été
piraté dans plusieurs hôpitaux donc je
pense là aussi que avant de vouloir
absolument enregistrer les données de
tous nos concitoyens peut-être il
faudrait commencer par euh par sécuriser
au maximum nos serveurs et s'assurer que
euh nous euh et que nous soyons en état
de garantir la sécurité pour toutes et
tous euh et les garantir la sécurité des
données de toutes et tous quelle
identité numérique allez-vous proposer
aux Français la question centrale est-ce
que c'est pas à
l'état de construire réellement une
identité numérique publique je veux
vraiment qu'il ait pas
de qui a pas
d'ambiguité dans ce qu'on discute là on
parle bien d'une d'une identité
numérique régalienne très concrètement
elle existe c'est France identité il y a
30000 français qui sont en train de
tester
France identité et il y aura encore pas
mal de français à partir du 15 octobre
qui vont le tester dans trois
départements puisqu'ils pourront avoir
leur permis de conduire sur
l'application et puis on pourra même
aller faire procuration pour les
européennes dans ces trois départements
avec cette application France identité
100 % en ligne donc là on parle vraiment
sur cet article là non mais pour bien
préciser sur cet article là on parle
d'une identité régalienne publique
étatique France identité je différencie
total
des solutions de vérification d'âge dont
on a parlé sur les articles 1 et 2 qui
peuvent être des sociétés
privées parfois startup avec succès
avec moins de succès voilà donc juste
pour bien préciser l'intention que soit
très clair nous allons maintenant
procéder au scrutin je vais donc mettre
au voix l'article 4 AC merci de bien
vouloir regagner vos
places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du
scrutin votant 89 exprimé 89 majorité 45
pour 53 contre 36 l'Assemblée nationale
a
adopté les députés ont adopté le
principe non contraignant de la
généralisation de l'identité numérique
en ligne mais faut-il pour autant lever
l'anonymat sur internet pour le rendre
plus sûr le rapporteur général du texte
Paul midi tente de convaincre les
opposition elles estiment la levée de
l'anonymat
liberticide le problème c'est le niveau
de violence sur les réseaux sociaux qui
est beaucoup plus élevé dans l'espace
numérique que dans la vie physique c'est
par exemple le cas de la jeune Linse qui
s'est suicidé il y a maintenant 3 mois
après cyberas cyber harcèlement scolaire
et c'est la maman de Linse qui nous
demande à nous de mettre fin à
l'impunité sur les réseaux sociaux et
puis c'est parce que on l'a vu nous
sommes 80 % de Français sur les réseaux
sociaux mais je crois je pense 100 %
dans cette assemblée
c'est tous les jours racisme
misogynie sexisme
lgbtphobie islamophobie antisémitisme il
y en a à tous les étages donc ce niveau
de violence c'est un problème premier
point deuxième point quelle est la cause
de ce niveau de violence moi je pense
pas qu'on soit tous devenus fous la
cause numéro 1 c'est le sentiment
d'anonymat sur les réseaux sociaux qui
génère un sentiment d'impunité qui fait
que pour beaucoup d'entre nous il n'y a
plus de limite donc on comprend tous que
quand on se sent totalement anonyme on a
une forme d'impunité ce qu'on propose
c'est de ne pas réinventer le fil à
couper le beur c'est tout simplement
d'appliquer les prinp princip qui marche
dans la vie physique à l'Espace
Numérique et ce principe il est très
clair c'est oui au pseudonymat non à
l'anonymat je marche dans la rue
heureusement j'ai pas l'obligation de
mettre mon nom sur ma veste j'ai le
droit au pseudonymat mais si je suis
arrêté par la police je dois décliner
mon identité je peux même être embarqué
au poste pendant 4 heures pour faire des
vérifications d'identité mais évidemment
si la police pense que je suis en train
de faire quelque chose d'illégal je ne
suis pas anonyme face à l'autorité si je
suis suspecter de faire quelque chose
d'illégal et donc ce qu'on propose c'est
tout simplement de faire la même chose
sur les réseaux sociaux dans l'espace
numérique je dois bien sûr avoir le
droit au pseudonyma je peux créer autant
de comptes que je veux sur les réseaux
sociaux avec un pseudonyme par exemple
polo 91 et la photo de mon chat aucun
problème j'ai le droit au pseudonymat
qu'est-ce qu'on entend d'un certain
nombre de groupes dans cette
assemblée c'est que si ces amendements
passaient c'est ce qui sera arrivé si on
les portait au vote
ça pouvait mettre en risque le vote
final sur le texte et ça ça n'est
l'intention de personne dans cette
assemblée j'espère que c'est l'intention
du plus grand nombre de nos collègues
ici de voter infin ce texte qui apporte
des choses extrêmement des avancées
extrêmement majeur pour sécuriser
l'espace numérique et être au service de
nos des Français et donc ce que je vous
propose en cohérence avec ce
raisonnement propose de retirer madame
la Présidente les amendements
869 900
870 875 et 874 voilà merci
[Applaudissements]
beaucoup je voudrais saluer le sens des
responsabilités du rapporteur général du
du président Mayard également des
députés signataires de ces amendements
en alors disant d'une part que ils ont
grâce à leur travail permis de faire
émerger un débat qui nous aura
d'ailleurs valu l'adoption en commission
modifié à la marge l'objectif ambitieux
que le Parlement a désormais fixé au
gouvernement pour le déploiement de
l'identité numérique ce qui est un grand
progrès et une un des acquis précieux de
ce texte si comme nous l'espérons tous à
la fin de son parcours législative il
est effectivement
adopté les amendements pour lever
l'anonymat en ligne sont finalement
retiré pour assurer le vote final du
texte nous sommes le mardi 17 octobre
2023 et l'Assemblée nationale va
procéder au vote solennel sur l'ensemble
du
texte l'ordre du jour appelle le vote
solennel sur le projet de loi visant à
sécuriser et réguler l'espace numérique
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est
clos voici le résultat du scrutin votant
561 exprimé 437 majorité 219 pour 360
contre 77 l'Assemblée nationale a adopté
je crois que monsieur le rapporteur
général vous soutiez dire un
mot oui merci madame la Présidente on
peut être collectivement très fier que
ce texte a été adopté il nous permettra
d'améliorer la sécurité sur l'espace
numérique de lutter contre le
cyberhcèlement qui gangraine nos réseaux
sociaux et qui gangraine l'espace
numérique il nous permettra de lutter
contre les arnaques en ligne merci chers
collègues contre les arnaques en ligne
grâce au filtres anti-arnaque et contre
l'exposition de nos enfants à la
pornographie et il nous permettra aussi
de réguler un C nombre d'activités dans
numérique très utile à
réguler l'Assemblée nationale a
largement adopté en première lecture ce
projet de loi numérique prochaine étape
la commission mixte paritaire en 2024 où
députés et sénateurs vont se mettre
d'accord sur une version finale du
projet de loi c'est la fin des grands
débats merci de nous avoir suivi et à
très bientôt sur
LCP
I